[Music]
in the hindi film industry in the 1940s
decades before it was known as bollywood
and just a few years before the
partition of british india
born muhammad yusuf khan in peshawar in
modern-day pakistan
he was asked to change his name to dilip
kumar when he began acting in films in
the city of bombay
kumar wrote in his biography that the
owner of production company bombay
talkies wanted him to have a name
that would be suitable for his audience
and so muhammad yusuf khan became philip
kumar on screen
but remained yusuf to those close to him
went on to be known by other names
tragedy king for his roles and
melancholic love stories such as devdas
india's best method actor for his
sincere performances
and the first khan
who were bollywood's biggest stars for
three decades from the 1990s
no actor can be bigger than the
substance which he portrays
i mean the character the story the
screenplay
and for any good or an enduring
performance
shahrukh you have to have
a good story kumar won the indian film
industries award for best actor a record
eight times including in its inaugural
year
1956.
his mughally 1960s
[Music]
where he played mughal emperor jahangid
is the highest grossing
indian film of all time when adjusted
for inflation
his talents were noticed outside india
but he turned down the role of sharif
ali in the 1962 blockbuster lawrence of
arabia
which went to egyptian actor omar sharif
kumar retired from acting in 1998 but
not from public life he was an advocate
for the rights of disadvantaged muslims
he traveled to pakistan to receive its
highest civilian honour
the nishane emptias the only indian to
have done so
he served on the upper house of india's
parliament in the early 2000s
and received the country's second
highest civilian honour for his
contribution to indian cinema
in 2015. with his passing india has lost
the last actor from the era of hindi
cinema
which produced the first stars elizabeth
paranam al jazeera new delhi